ouais c'est c'est du vrai
ça faisait longtemps que j'avais pas vu
une scène allumer tous pour ça je prends
peu le temps si j'ose ouais c'est fou
bonjour et du public enfin oui salut ya
trois personnes qui me répondent c'est
ça le monde d'après je suis content
j'espère que que tout le monde va bien
je suis très très heureux d'être d'être
ici parmi vous ça fait très longtemps
que je suis pas monté sur une scène donc
vous jeu las la suite là y'a personne si
je parle comme ça donc il faut que je
reste bien en face de vous je regarde
des gens qui me regardent et iri mais je
les entends pas rire je ne vois que ça
c'est marrant ça c'est rigolo à monsieur
qui a fait signer ouais c'est assez
déroutant
je me sens un peu comme un américain
avec une grosse bouteille d'alcool
pendant la prohibition vraiment cgt sur
une terrasse à préparer la conférence là
je suis sur scène je suis à deux doigts
d'aller dans un club mais je sais que
les clubs sont fermés les mardis soirs
de pandémie j'espère que tout le monde
va bien je suis je m'appelle duel promet
nano j'ai 29 ans et je suis humoriste en
stand by
reconverti en chef à domicile enfin
surtout mon domicile pour être très
honnête avec vous donc oui pour tous les
gens qui s'attendaient à de la
pertinence à des leçons de vie leçons de
morale c'est le moment de s'en aller
parce que tout ce que je vais dire va
être remplie de vacuité si j'ose là
c'est assez fou je suis très honoré
d'être invité à un ted sais je vous
avoue que c'était un petit peu un des
objectifs dans la vie c'est d'être
invité un talkie de venir parler en tant
qu'humoriste reconnu venir parler de ma
profession de comment j'ai réussi à
perdurer à travers les âges
en tant que personnage public donné des
conseils peut-être ceux qui débutent et
pouvoir distribuer mon savoir ici dans
un thé tôt j'aurais fait vous savez
j'aurais fait
des citations j'aurais dit que le plus
important c'est le travail c'est le
travail qui m'a permis d'être là où je
suis aujourd'hui j'aurais pu être repris
par des pages instagram objectif
millionnaire vous savez où j'aurai fait
une une métaphore hyper inspirante et
hyper parlante sur du jardinage où
j'aurais dit qu'il fallait pas avoir
peur d'être une tulipe dans un champ de
marguerite mais pas qu'eux mais que
cette tulipe
en fait elle ne sait pas que c'est une
tulipe au milieu des marguerites donc lé
tout déçu d'être de ne pas être utilisé
comme les autres margherita je t'aime un
petit peu moi aussi passionnément parce
qu'elle sait pas que c'est une tulipe
elles n'osent pas être une tulipe basse
qu'elle pense être une marguerite
j'aurais été repris sur ses pages dans
cette agréable avec de la musique épique
et tout plein de jeunes auraient fait le
salut à toi jeune entrepreneur en ayant
vu ma vidéo donc
donc ouais je je je voilà je suis invité
un ted talk en ligne en pleine pandémie
50% en allemand sur la thématique du
punk j'ai un peu l'impression de m'être
fait arnaquer par la vie je veux pas
j'ai commandé un scooter à noël j'ai
reçu un vélomoteur mais voilà c'est pas
c'est pas si grave je sais à peu près la
même forme ça roule un petit peu moins
vite mais j'ai quand même des bouchons
chrome et donc je suis content ça c'est
cool non je suis très content d'être
d'être invité ici merci d'ailleurs à la
ouate à tout le staff de de m'avoir
invité dans cette danse e teltow
qu'autour du du punk einstein disait il
ne faut pas il ne faut pas juger un
poisson sur sa capacité à grimper un
arbre devant vous ce soir vous avez une
truite dans une forêt pour être très
honnête avec vous je pense que quand je
compte on prononce le mot punk c'est pas
du tout cette dégaine là qui arrive en
tête en premier pour être très honnête
avec vous moi en tout cas la notion de
punk c'est pas c'est pas ça alors oui
j'ai vu les tatouages
ok j'ai des tatouages mais je crois que
aujourd'hui pour être vraiment pas comme
tout le monde il faut je pense ne pas
avoir de tatouages je pense que le vrai
punk aujourd'hui il n'a pas de tatouage
je pense que le vrai punk il se fait
vacciner auprès des gens qui sont
malades
il va directement voir les gens là
va chez astrazeneca ça c'est vraiment
s'il est vraiment punk tu vas le vrai
punk
il met le lait avant les céréales et ça
directement dans la bouche
le vrai punk il anesthésie son dentiste
pour s'enlever lui même les dents de
sagesse d'accord moi je suis pas je suis
pas bon c'est vrai le seul truc punk que
j'ai qui se dégage de moi c'est ma
dentition s'il ya quelqu'un qui a pas
une dentition comme les autres je pense
que c'est moi je pense que rien de plus
punk que les dents qui font un pogo pour
être très honnête avec vous donc
donc je peux quand même garder je peux
quand même garder cet aspect là de punk
c'est vrai qu'ils qui de plus punk que
l'animateur de cash
cette admission subversive et provoquant
ce qui passe à 3 heures du matin sur des
chaînes comme arte vaille ce jour serena
danser une fois il faut j'ai j'ai osé
dans cette émission dire mille balles
cash
vous avez pour briser les codes enfoncer
les portes du conventionnel
le lendemain j'ai été recadrée recadré
par yvette 70,3 en vous un courrier de
téléspectateurs qui disaient que je
respectais pas l'argent donc aujourd'hui
je dis mille francs cache pas ce que je
suis vraiment une pauvre merde et que
j'ose pas faire autrement
cm je pense que c'est ça le vrai truc
punk qu'a voulu faire le staff de ce thé
talk aujourd'hui c'est d'inviter
quelqu'un de pas du tout punk pour
parler d'un truc punk attendant ils ont
voulu faire autrement en invitant
quelqu'un qui n'a pas l'habitude de
faire autrement pour pouvoir faire
autrement je crois que c'est un peu ça
m'a pas très honnête avec vous je me
sens pas là je me sens pas du tout
légitime aujourd'hui c'est pas grave
parce que c'est aussi important d'avoir
ce point de vue là parce que moi je suis
toujours dans les règles
les rares fois où je transgresse des
choses je n'en dors pas vraiment jeu si
je pense que je grille un feu rouge je
suis à deux doigts de trinité la police
cantonale c'est pour dire à quel point
je n'arrive pas à transgresser des
règles j'ai acheté des chaussures de
punk j'ai acheté des creepers c'est des
chaussures en cuir
ça m'a fait des cloques j'ai arrêté de
les porter c'est pour vous dire à quel
point je me sens pas punk et je ne suis
pas punk je pense que c'est ça qui est
important c'est d'avoir plusieurs
plusieurs points de vue et oui aussi ce
tradition d'inviter les humoristes pour
débriefer un petit peu aussi les les
passages d
autre intervenant mais étant donné qu'il
ya eu trois passages en allemand chicane
enfin ce shooting quoi je peux pas faire
ça je suis désolé je pense que cette rue
que je peux faire c'est de vérifier
s'ils ont mis le verbe à la fin quand
ils ont commencé leurs phrases par weill
mais c'est tout quoi à bord hadas var 0
pédagogique à l'eau sourit et good
tènement comverge pilotes comme comme
comme j'ai quand même me lancer dans une
présentation
parce que on est là pour ça et là pour
faire des présentations parce que alors
je suis pas inquiet présentation punk
j'ai beaucoup de peine à me mettre pour
être très honnête avec vous aujourd'hui
on est sur l'honnêteté aujourd'hui c'est
un an on partage j'ai pas s'il voit à
quel point vous pouvez me dire quelque
chose derrière votre écran façon je vous
entendrez pas mais on est honnête on est
honnête vous vous et moi j'ai eu
beaucoup de peine à me mettre
et parce que la conférence a été
repoussée repoussé à plusieurs reprises
je sais pas si vous aussi vous avez les
intervenants cette impression là c'est
que elle est vraiment cette date là
ensuite non c'est cette date là et cette
date là et pourquoi ce paramètre il est
important à retenir c'est parce que moi
je souffre d'un syndrome x appelle le
syndrome e m au plus connu sous le nom
de syndrome de l'étudiant mal organisé
bo s en anglais et voilà normalement
j'aurais dû envoyer un powerpoint qui
s'afficherait normalement ici mais un
des symptômes du de l'om hausse est de
ne pas du tout respecté les délais et
l'envoi du powerpoint était un délai
intermédiaires ou délai final qui était
cette présentation aujourd'hui et bien
sûr souffrant de cette maladie
les délais intermédiaires sont
complètement éradiqué il n'existe plus
bon après y'a des il ya des gens qui
souffrent de ce syndrome qui sont
asymptomatiques et qui respecte ces
délais mais moi je suis un cas assez
lourde
ce syndrome de l'étudiant mal organisé
donc à l'aide de ce powerpoint qui n'est
pas du tout là j'aurais pu vous montrer
à quel point c'est difficile pour moi de
de faire cette présentation parce que vu
que la date butoir a été repoussée
moi je travaille la veille d'accord et
si la veille elle est déplacée à
et encore plus loin la motivation est
diluée je sais pas si vous arrivez à
comprendre j'ai passé derrière votre
écran ça vous parle j'ai passé les
étudiants mal organisé parmi vous en
tout cas on est ensemble fort twenty
d'ailleurs c'est la fête nationale des
étudiants mal organisé un pour ceux qui
sont la référence
voilà j'avais deux solutions qui
s'offraient à moi j'avais soit proposer
quelque chose de sérieux soient joués le
margoulin un autre symptômes du syndrome
e et mot est le propre aux et du tout
parce que arriver à une conférence sont
rien ça c'est vraiment punk donc ce que
j'ai fait comme vous avez pu le
constater ça un subtil mélange des 2 1
donc je suis assez content de l'effet
que j'ai créée mais si vous voulez quand
même mon point de vue d'humoristes sur
l'alternatif la différence le le punk je
peux vous le donner même si voilà c'est
c'est comme une pièce qu'on lance dans
une fontaine le veut il va jamais se
réaliser
ça pousse à ma vision du punk ces deux
en tout cas moi c'est de faire comme les
autres mais autrement je pense que c'est
ça le lac lescout saisissez la nuance
faire comme les autres notamment jean
claude van damme sort de ce corps oui
moi par exemple j'ai l'exemple typique
de faire comme les autres mais je le
fais autrement je sais pas si vous
arrivez à voir c'est parce que il ya un
facteur qui est crucial la danse et le
fait que je sois moi et le fait que je
sois moi bah du coup je ne suis pas les
autres ce qui fait que indéniablement je
suis pas un autre samedi france est
désossé d'être moi et être soi c'est ne
pas être un autre et moi j'aime les
autres parce que dans 20 30 ans il y en
aura plus voilà une autre référence à
jean claude van damme est ce que moi il
faut jamais faire comme les autres parce
que faire comme les autres c'est ne pas
faire comme les autres c'est ce qui te
permet d'être toi et je pense que c'est
ça le le message un peu sérieux que j'ai
voulu j'ai voulu faire transparaître
je fais comme les autres autrement dit
moi typiquement mon boulot c'est de
faire des blagues tout le monde fait des
blagues on est d'accord tout le monde
fait des blagues
j'ai des potes à moi de mon entourage
qui sont mille fois plus drôle que moi
mais ils sont pas humoriste c'est tout
le monde fait des blagues votre votre
voisin fait des blagues maman fait des
blagues
les suisses à tout le monde fait des
blagues d'accord mais qu'est ce qui fait
que moi yoann romaine
anoh parmi tout le monde j'arrive à
faire de ses blagues
mon métier c'est parce que je fais ces
blagues mais c'est moi qui les fais
c'est que c'est moi c'est pas les autres
j'ai passé aura le copier coller de mon
powerpoint dans liens dans la
description n'est pas du tout sur
youtube sais pas ce qui se passe en gros
c'est une chance de pouvoir payer mon
loyer en blague parce que je fais ce que
ce qui me définit ce qui me rallie à mon
identité propre moi je suis humoriste je
me définis comme humoriste et je fais ça
je paye mon loyer en blague parce que
c'est ce que j'ai envie de faire
j'aurais pu payer mon loyer en plats
cuisinés j'aurais pu payer mon loyer en
coupe en bois coupé j'aurais pu payer
mon loyer en calculs effectués mais moi
j'ai choisi de payer mon loyer
en blague et pourquoi c'est important
c'est parce que c'est pas c'est pas
comme les autres j'ai ya les autres
humoristes qui font ça mais heureusement
qu'il ya d'autres personnes comme moi
qui sont pas les factions les autres
mais qui sont et on est en fait comme
pas tout le monde ok donc je pense que
c'est ça le truc
le truc le plus punk que j'ai réussi à
faire dans ma vie c'est de faire comme
les autres mais autrement
merci beaucoup c'est et johan franzen
[Applaudissements]